Let's go next to our caller from the 3 1 4
area code caller from 3 1 4.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hello, David.
This is Alan and I am calling from St. Charles,
Missouri.
What's on your mind today, Alan?
I was.
Wondering that if Hillary Clinton had been
the president.
How do you think this whole covered?
19 The pandemic was played out in America.
It would still be a pandemic, but our response
would have been closer to what South Korea
did than what we have today.
So as an example, Hillary Clinton would not
have become president.
And in 2018 disbanded the pandemic response
team.
She wouldn't have done that.
Hillary Clinton would not have ignored the
color coded 69 page pandemic response playbook
that the Obama administration created after
Ebola and left behind.
Hillary Clinton would not have had such administration
turnover over that.
More than half of the people who were briefed
on pandemic response in 2017 by the Obama
administration would have already been fired
or resigned, as is the case with the Trump
administration.
So can we say we would have been South Korea
with Hillary Clinton as president?
Of course not.
But just on those three issues alone, we would
have been far better suited to deal with this
than we are under Donald Trump.
It's very easy to go up to try to rewrite
history or to have these alternative histories.
If this that the other thing.
But there's no question that on just those
three points alone, we would have been so
much better off with Hillary Clinton running
this than Donald Trump.
And I also wondered, you know, you think in
the long term after this has passed that we
will ever get back to the point of having
packed stadiums and sold out concerts with
tens of thousands of people?
You know, I think we will.
I think we will.
And part of the reason why I think that is
it it is common that it always feels like
things will never go back to the way they
were.
And in some ways, sometimes things don't like
things will always be a little different.
But I believe it could take a while.
But eventually we will get back to that, hopefully
with more precautions, better functioning
systems and more preparedness to deal with
this if it is not if but when it happens again.
Kind of like after nine eleven.
Yes.
It felt like it wouldn't, you know, flying
was never going to just be flying again.
And you know, it it is different.
We have the TSA now.
We didn't before.
It's not the same.
But by and large, things do go back to mostly
to the way that that they were.
Alan, thank you so much for the call.
I so appreciate, appreciated and appreciate
the thoughtful question.